all right guys
bang bang i've got mark here thanks so
much for doing this man i'm super
excited
thanks for having me on the show so i'm
mark nadal and i'm the founder of era
which has
about 30 million monthly active users on
our decentralized database and
cybersecurity protocol
called gun we got some pretty legendary
investors behind us
tim draper and mark benioff of
salesforce as well as others and
a sweet og team from the old school days
of
marty sirius malmy who was satoshi's
first contributor and my job here today
is to tell you about the evolution of
the decentralized web
and how over the next one or two years
100 million people will be onboarding
into decentralization and its impact to
our lives
people and market i love it man uh
before we get into the decentralized
uh web and kind of all the nuances and
intricacies there
let's talk about your background and
kind of where did you grow up and then
how did you eventually get into
technology and what you're doing today
i've had the bountiful privilege of
growing up in california
san diego so i've never known what
bad weather is like and that has given
me a very different
view um thanks to
to just the affluence of the area of
post scarcity
so i do look at all of the existing
models
of money finance bitcoin blockchains
debt government currencies with a lot of
skepticism because
i'm an internet baby right i the
internet is a fundamentally
transformative technology
that takes people out of the environment
that they were in before
so if you were scared of the school
ground bully
you don't have to deal with that anymore
unfortunately centralization has led
back to the school
ground bully which is facebook just
wants to recommend
your high school friends but the power
of the internet is to connect to people
who need to be connected ought to be
connected
and should be connected but are distant
and apart
so the internet is this kind of vital
transition and that's kind of the
evolution i went through myself
personally
i was focused on ideas and philosophy
and mathematics
but without being able to apply it i
couldn't have any impact on the world
and so i jumped into learning how to
code
and very quickly we got some publicity
and press and my
my centralized servers fell apart they
caught on fire like the classic
silicon valley tv show or just like
things are not working and the analogy
here
is that it doesn't matter some nerd
words if your application server if your
cdn if your front end
code is all working the database is the
heart
to your system it pumps the blood to
your whole
system so if the database is centralized
and it goes down
it doesn't matter if your brain is
working fine doesn't matter your arms
are working fine you don't have blood
to power that system and so i got
interested in decentralized technology
for the sake of resilience
efficiency and scalability but it's also
been a wonderful journey of discovering
all these other uh perks and benefits
and you know censorship
resistance and um component so that's
kind of in a nutshell um
i could do hours of talking on just that
that transition and growth
but it's why i'm passionate about the
internet i think it can impact humanity
and why it's extraordinarily important
not only for financial reasons but also
for
um humanitarian reasons that we make
this transition into a more resilient
future
that is better for everybody and brings
people together um rather than
connecting them with yet another
advertisement school ground bully or
uh toxic news feed absolutely and so
maybe let's talk a little bit about what
was the centralized service that you'd
built and kind of you know took off and
really drove you to uh
to the ultimate conclusion that the
decentralized database would be
an important piece of infrastructure
that was about a decade ago
there's a collaborative web design tool
called excelsir
there is an old
all things digital um interview of me
showing off the technology so you can
see my transition from then
to now and these days it's called low
code
no code um it's a very popular movement
and i'm kind of a little bit jealous
because it's like ah
like that that is actually one of the
the passion points i'm interested in
solving is creating tools for amateurs
that outperform um professionals because
i want that type of empowerment for
everybody i don't want people to have to
pay for things um in order to be a
professional
that can create an impact i want i want
tools
that enable the everyone
but unfortunately
this rabbit trail right well then you
discover that it's
2010 2011 and you would think we can
auto scale
right no no
just having 300 signups on our website
crashed our mongodb database instance
web scales developers call it and uh
you know i just i just spun up a huge
machine
um for the in-between to make it last
but
those sleepless nights of getting pager
calls at 3am
and debugging what's going wrong just
you know
led me to a point where it's like i i
think
using my math background and my
understanding of physics and distributed
systems
i can build something that's a little
bit more resilient a little bit more
powerful and
hey so far we're doing it i'm handling
30 million
users a month rather than 300
ups so um lots of details there but
it'll start to bore people on the
technical side yeah so let's talk a
little bit about the centralized
internet and i
couldn't agree more with you in terms of
the uh the positive impact and kind of
net gain that the world has had because
of the internet and kind of the
uh everything from increasing the rate
of communication increasing the
connectivity of kind of the human nodes
in the globe uh to literally just making
us more efficient
and kind of better informed and all
these things but there are problems
right and so maybe talk a little bit
just about how you
see the i'll call it the legacy uh
centralized internet
um and kind of what those problems are
and why really the decentralized web
can uh can address them i'm gonna back
up for a second
my last kind of explanation was pointing
more towards developers and
engineers this i want to really point
towards like
markets and investors and transition
that we're going through so um i always
start
if if you are doing day trading you
should be doing a lot of math
and one of the most exciting algorithms
i've found
um is called the handshake problem
and handshake problems is a step back
and then i'll apply it to
the internet in your question is when
you're at a business meeting
how many individual um business cards
get exchanged at that conference um
such that you know you're only changing
one business card for each person that
you're meeting
and most business people will know
there is a high advantage to kind of
speed dating right you want to get as
many cards as possible
to see what the opportunity is so that
way then later you can follow up with a
particular
a value value-add or proposition but if
you only chat with one or two people at
the conference the entire night
you don't know what you missed out on so
that that's represented mathematically
in graph theory is what's called the
handshake problem and
this wine set being like the fundamental
equation that i'm arguing
drives value-add for the internet and
people
into the future and here's why um
you don't get startups
you don't get innovation unless you get
recombination
unless you get people who bump into each
other and they discover
they have similar competing ideas and
they're able to engage with each other
so before the internet
you only could bump into people in
physical meat space
right and that's why a lot of people are
attracted to cities
in fact like you literally have a
geographic density in order to increase
people as particles bumping into each
other to get this type of spark
um hopefully that rather than here in
california's elsewhere in the world like
you know you don't want a spark that
starts a forest fire you want a city
that people interact with each other and
sparks and creates startup that then
drives innovation
because those ideas are transformative
and it can be executed on
um but now we can move this online right
in fact
we can algorithmize all of it and this
is where
i think the transition from um
prior services like oracle ibm
um the old industry of what computers
were
supposed to be into things like
uber and airbnb is happening
because airbnb is saying
you know the value add is not in the
taxis
that we actually own okay it's in our
ability to do
a matchmaking algorithm across the
network
so there's kind of two trade-offs you
have
venture capitalists who have a large
network that's very deep
that they can reorient okay and then you
have
very shallow networks that are huge like
bitcoin at
t facebook uh airbnb
uber and what's odd is that the
centralized companies like google and
facebook
don't understand the value of the
shallow but
largeness of their network because
they're just using that to control
information flow from a
um a censorship or moderation
perspective but the companies that are
really like
going through these very quick rapid
economic transformations
that you know different markets uber
compared to facebook but
um that are almost a threat to the
overall
capital um allocation is is the
companies are saying hey
what if the value is our network itself
and how we recombine it to find
and produce more value add for everybody
in the community
and i predict actually and as we're
going to
end my ramble is that you're going to
see money itself
evolve into a network system bitcoin is
extraordinarily important because it
takes
the existing debt model um
the scarcity model and removes
middlemen like banks but i'm here to say
that that
is a very important but tiny transition
step
towards this overall decentralized
movement that's happening
and i'll leave it there for and all the
rest of my thoughts and
yeah so as you kind of think through
that right um
there is an argument that uh the lack of
ownership by a single individual
organization
is no longer a nice to have
but has become a necessity in this new
world
across different applications what i
mean by that is i continue to
think a lot about uh this theme of
centralization
is uh a business risk right and
and you can switch out the word business
risk for uh other things like an
individual risk or whatever
but centralization has no longer become
this thing that you need centralization
to get efficiency
and therefore you can give up the
resiliency right decentralization can
actually now
ensure you have the resiliency and also
we're now getting to the point where you
can have efficiency as well
how do you think through that yes so
first of all
right there's kind of three levels to
the market there's the consumer market
there's the lobby market and there's the
nation state market so depending upon
where you care to
invest or put money or think about they
definitely have different scales so i
want to first state that
we're still transitioning into the
internet era and that means
that like any money and investment still
put into
you know saying um there's still a lot
of the world
that we're transitioning just onto the
cloud and centralized at
centralized internet style efficiency so
i don't think
you're really going to lose money long
term over even those investments even
though it's against kind of my
philosophical view um
and then there's the government scale
stuff which i
let's let's not we can discuss that
later but in terms of like consumer
market
yes um especially with covet
accelerating stuff you already saw
a lot of fortune 500s moving on to
what's called edge cloud and that's like
kind of this latest bleeding bleeding
edge
um pun intended their transition
that only innovative organizations are
thinking about and it's important
because
you got consumers all around the world
and you did get
the coordination consistency of having
google thing
um being able to centralize things but
now most of these companies are
realizing hey
like the only way for us to compete in
the market now is to just like have
slightly faster websites
than our competitor because that's going
to so explain this because i think
there's a lot of people who are
listening who
when you say edge or you talk about pops
or any of this stuff they're gonna have
no clue
what that is so just like what in plain
english like what is
edge computing or edge cloud computing
yeah
so imagine you have a billion users
spread across seven different continents
before it was easier to just manage all
of that by having them point to
one server in amazon
east you know virginia or san francisco
or london let's just say you had one
server
and all eight billion users eventually
um
trickled back to that server that then
processed information
saved the data and pushed it back out so
this can be seen incredibly with big
frustration when you're traveling
at an airport you go up to um you know
tsa
and you know to print your pat your your
ticket
and it's like oh you know enter your
your
um flight number and it's like oh let's
wait 30 seconds to be like oh shoot good
thing i have you know global pass or
whatever because it's like
my play is going to take off in one hour
but the stupid machine is taking
30 seconds to look up this information
and that's because
even though the airline should
know that you are going to be at that
airport
they're still having that machine talk
to some server on the opposite side of
the world
and that's ridiculous that's done and
then they're doing what's called global
consistency in that data
um and there's there's all sorts of like
terrorists and security reasons why you
might do that but that doesn't mean you
can't say
hey um we know somebody's gonna be
faking your passport is not gonna be
coming from
australia if you are flying out of of
jfk
right so edge
systems is about saying hey well we know
that we can actually push that
processing that logic
down to that terminal in jfk itself
or let's say a a data center that's
running um
in the back pipes somewhere on jfk or
nearby
right so then when you show up at the
airport rather than
the stupid terminal talking to london or
australia some computer far far away
you actually get instantaneous results
because the data
is there it it's literally physically
present with you
so when you type in your number the
response can be instantaneous and
and that's now how these fortune 500s
are realizing that they have to compete
they have to make
the experience be just slightly faster
than
everybody else in the market that
they're competing with and they have
slightly fast
their experiences that um whether the
user is cognitively aware of it or not
psychologically adds up over time to
creating the retention
that sticks them on that out rather than
others would it be fair
to classify or kind of describe
um edge computing has obviously got some
aspects or elements of decentralization
to it right you're literally pushing it
away
closer to the end user for performance
reasons but
um is it a kind of a balance between
there's still
centralized ownership of the system
there's still centralized
design but the implementation
is uh not decentralized but it's less
centralized than it previously was is
that like a fair way to talk about
what's going on there
absolutely however in the blockchain
world it's easy to start getting some
things um
conflated right so while blockchain is
decentralized
in ownership it is not decentralized in
operation
effectively every single block there's
the
you know the winner that controls that
block and so that means you still have
to be connected to the internet to the
network to the blockchain
in order for things to resolve so
blockchain doesn't necessarily resolve
that airport example that i was giving
however it does resolve the ownership or
the equity or the financial side of the
equation which
is incredibly incredibly important so
there's decentralization with respect to
operation
you know performance which yes is what
more edge computing is about
and is more the side that i'm um dealing
with
and then there's decentralization around
ownership or equity or property
and there's a whole interesting like
transition there
which i'm because a lot of your users
are from that space i i want to quickly
note
that before it was intellectual property
you owned the code and that was the
value add
then it switched to like oh wait like
ibm oracle like
these these sas services these internet
as a services these
are are just taking our code and and
racking in millions of users and making
money
and so then it transitioned to oh like
we own the gateway
right um and one of the brilliant thing
about satoshi
is he came along and said actually if
you own the seed
to the network you get the benefits of
both without the operational complexity
of either
right and that's like fundamentally
profound from um
an ownership perspective it's separate
from the monetary or financial side it's
saying
actually what exists that is valuable is
not
the intellectual property of the code
itself that you're trying to sell
it's not the gateway or the server that
you're trying to sell
it is actually saying um what is the
authority of the network itself
because that is the network effect that
everything
builds on top of and if you own a seed
the authenticity
the origin to that network um
then it doesn't matter if people fork
your code or
spin up a competing bitcoin like
nobody's going to use it
it can be completely open source you can
literally shovel
the source code and um to to your
competitors and it doesn't matter
um because you know that it's the
network that is valuable
it is the network that's valuable so
talk to me about
um kind of this idea of resiliency
versus efficiency right um
chamoth uh palpatine came on uh at the
kind of the beginning of this pandemic
and one of the the main messages he had
was the u.s economy has chased
efficiency
over resiliency and therefore we
basically scoured the
globe found all these places where we
could go put our manufacturing
facilities our supply chains
kind of all these different things that
led to greater efficiencies
which ultimately led to uh more
profitability or at least the allure of
more profits
but what it did was it exposed a
us-based company
to less resiliency because obviously
when a global pandemic
happens the second that other countries
are affected you now don't have control
over your operations there's all these
kind of issues
and so one of the his main messages was
hey we are going to go back to a more
balanced
view of we need efficiency but we also
need resiliency right it can't just be
all efficiency no resiliency or all
resiliency no efficiency there's got to
be some balance there
and so how do you think about that when
applied to the decentralized web
and uh looking at your reaction right
now you may not even agree with that
framework that he used
yeah i mean i'm not saying he's wrong
but i think there's a conflation between
the consumer market
and the government market there right so
a lot of
take apple's recent move which will date
this episode um
to using india as a manufacturing plant
instead of
china i don't think that's necessarily
i think it's because of regulatory
efficiency not even necessarily product
um
efficiency it would be a lot more
efficient right
to have the market that you're selling
to
um let's say primarily the us
historically um
and london europe for
selling your market but the products
already there because then it's just
more cost efficient in terms of
uh you don't have to ship the items or
the damage that happens
in that logistics process but that was
the kind of win for
for apple is they realize oh india's is
growing market they're selling
um higher flagship films too but also
has
probably unethically right a comparable
level of
sweatshop um um operational stuff but
they're gonna have to figure out quality
control there as well but tim cook is
the king of that he made that transition
for apple in the first place
so i don't i don't necessarily know we
could peg global operations
purely as efficiency versus resilience
i would say that that playing the
regulatory game that lobbying market and
the kind of government level
is more about resilience
than it is about efficiency um but that
kind of just depends upon what
scope you're dealing with so uh maybe
maybe i should just skip past it
and tell me the question again yeah so
talk a little bit just about the
trade-off between resiliency and
efficiency
especially when it comes to the
decentralized web and the perspective
here is
uh there's a lot of people who say hey
it sounds great to have a decentralized
internet but isn't that going to be
slower or less performance than uh the
centralized version
i think you actually think the opposite
but but kind of help people understand
that trade-off between decentralization
uh
resiliency versus efficiency i am so in
the weeds on this
right so i apologize but it's like if
the goal is going for his power
um and control
then sure centralization is more
efficient but
like like if you want authoritarianism
if you want totalitarianism uh if you
want
um if you want a master planned economy
like okay i can't argue against that
um but on in all other categories
like down to the physics of biology
ecosystems the universe mass
distribution
markets free markets um business
operations
and and that efficiency and resilience
is just
the way that the universe has played out
and how
humans like even your brain distributes
your memories across
um your the neurons and so it's like
mean i don't even know whether it's in
the neurons or not but
so i don't know even where to start
because
the statement that efficiency and
resilience is a trade-off between
centralization
and decentralization is is
is would you agree
would you agree that a centralized
social network or centralized company is
more efficient and less resilient
what is the end goal like it only has to
do with
what the goal we're trying to attain is
um
so if it's profit
no like no san fran hiring engineers in
san francisco is expensive
and the coven transition is certainly
like showcasing that there's plenty of
extraordinary talent that's been around
for a long time
that is that you know a third or a
fraction you know a fraction of that
um price now obviously there's ethics
around
how you wind up you know paying um
employees and stuff but
but the the only i think efficiency
about centralization is
around like mind share
tribalism and and
like colt signaling um and those cults
could be very very very big
which means they're definitionally not a
cult but i
sorry i'm probably throwing you i love
it
um so yeah the question
i don't even know how to start because i
so fundamentally disagree with
the basis of the question that so tell
me about in terms of the decentralized
web right
why is this important okay
um first of all i want to start with
the humanitarian reasons right which is
hopefully we view humans whether it's
for moral reasons or economic reasons
as potential contributors to an economy
or potential contributors to
um this planet unfortunately
um industrialization has kind of changed
the view of humans from
uh something to extract from and our
extractors
rather than value add or creators and
that kind of
creates a lot of like political
ideological and religious
uh division between people which we can
go into if you want but that's
very philosophical i think what's going
to be more applied is talking about
the market transition and
the internet originally was
founded on this idea of academics being
able to
collaborate from afar which think about
that like that that's almost a dangerous
idea
because a university's entire ip
and its entire um ability to control
and productize and profit is by taking
minds
bringing them inside a literally walled
garden campus
and and selling external access to that
and the internet was then those
scientists being like hey
but like i really know somebody over at
mit or kel tech that i want to talk to
and and do research collaboration on and
so that you know they got that going
thanks tim
berners-lee um but but suddenly that
exploded
right suddenly had exploded to
businesses realizing that they could
collaborate online and then humans
realizing well
you know a corporation is just a body of
humans literally from the latin
um so then people from a social
standpoint
realize that like they might get along
with friends
on the other side of the planet rather
than in their neighborhood
um that goes back to my my kind of bully
comments from earlier
and again that transitions right out of
the cold war too so there's
there's even that legacy of like the
nationalism of like
you know you're american you're not
american and it's easy to
issue propaganda when the nation states
control the telecommunications
um they control the radio tower so then
you don't have friends
or you don't hear stories to empathize
with people outside of your nation state
so they are the other there's this
really great talk called the empathic
civilization
about this evolution over history um
there's like a rsa animate like one of
those ted
um really cool i recommend people watch
it so but again that's like more the
philosophy stuff and the transition
between
um ideologies and nationalism and
religion and philosophy over time um
but now right like we just take this for
granted
which is uh we have friends from around
the world because
we might get um a better relationship
with them because we vibe with them
better
so then how does this impact right the
transition in the market itself
like i'm trying to make this historic in
a lot of my
my comments around money and finance and
markets i'm trying to
to to say hey you can do your day
trading where you're you know you're
doing math
and checking up variables and down
variables and the calculus
for what you're going to do for this
next week or the next month
but you're always going to get a return
if you understand the historical trends
and the larger and larger trends and how
there's these onboardings that happen of
larger and larger populations
anyways so um i i'm always trying to
appeal to
this historical narrative and understand
these transitions so the importance of
the decentralized web is
the exact same thing that's playing out
in the case of like the governments and
the corporations and
individuals okay where value
is going to accrue and build and develop
um that will return investments
is increasingly in individuals
like you joe rogan like joe rogan is
doing more traffic and podcast downloads
than cnn
right like sorry maybe it's like half
the size i forget the number
it's incredible that a individual
right because the internet can amass a
network effect
that rivals mainstream um systems so
the importance is primarily the
humanitarian transition of us being able
to empathize with more and more people
over time rather than
on bipartisan um by-product
competition that capitalism and
socialism kind of drives this
this this forcing function this um
uh winner takes all which then
ultimately boils down to two competing
factions that then drives uh
i'm rambling here i'm just gonna go with
it because i this is one of my more
important longer term things i'm trying
to talk to people about is that like
look
fundamentally capitalism and socialism
are zero-sum games
which means in order for that zero-sum
game to play out
um over time there's what's called
peridot efficiency and 80-20 rule
in terms of how um uh wealth
income divide is going to happen and
resource allocations are going to
develop and once you have that
there's always going to be a monopoly
but at least in capitalism
there is competition of that monopoly
and it boils down to two companies um
and then
also same thing happens in politics
boils down to
two sides because that's the fastest way
in a zero-sum system
where you have this kind of balanced
lever going back and forth
they can um duke it out with each other
it's the most efficient way
but unfortunately both sides are
fundamentally playing the same game
okay they are on the same side if you
can tribalize people's emotions
to vote based off of fear then
that's how you get better voting power
if you can tribalize people's dollars
to get them to pay for a product you
know
starbucks versus uh seattle's best
but they're both owned by the same
parent company like
um you you want people to think that
there's competition
so that way from a market standpoint the
people who do want to
go against the system flip over to
whatever
the opposite is but what a lot of people
don't realize is that the opposite side
as a company is usually owned by the
same parent company as the monopoly
and then the same thing with with the
government and politics stuff like
it it's all voting extraction in the
same way that money
is money extraction and what's the
answer
what's the solution yeah the answer is
these network effects which is you don't
want to reward
people based off of um scarcity
because most people don't even value
scarcity anymore
that's a dangerous statement to say on a
podcast with investors
we spend so much time scrolling through
these toxic news feeds
that clearly we're getting some sort of
value out of
these toxic news feeds um and i have a
whole
blog on this free dot eco which explains
um this transition into what i call a
post-scarcity
or um non-zero-sum economic model
and it honestly this happened with the
internet
but nobody knows how to measure it and
the way you actually
measure the ebitda or the value of a
company
i argue is looking at the handshake
problem and calculating the handshake of
that network effect
that is the maximum potential value that
can be unlocked from a network
if it is utilized however most of these
companies
are still busy trying to productize and
scarcitize
their um their their features
that they are not looking at the network
for the sake
of recombination on an opportunity
they're looking at the network for
extraction and that creates these
dystopian centralizations these
dystopian
privacy violations um now i'm really off
topic that so
like the importance of the d web is is
across financial humanitarian
efficiency resilient it's it's
everything like
it as a young kid growing up in the 90s
i was sad that i wasn't born a little
bit earlier to
partake in the the internet revolution
and be one of those pioneers but now i'm
realizing
that the most exciting transition that
humanity is going forward
was that the internet was just a base
nervous system
for us to start with and
now we have the opportunity for the
first time in like two thousand three
thousand four thousand years
to change the economic model well okay
sorry capitalism and social has only
been around for
175 and 300 years itself
um uh that's going to start another
ramble about just how quickly
people transition but i gotta i gotta
stop because i think i wanna come back
to more applied
uh things for the audience rather than
ending with like this
philosophy uh spew i wanna come back to
like practical implications
so i'm gonna i'll stop there so so help
me understand what exactly you guys are
building
and also let's talk a little bit about
why
uh this is like a integral part
of the decentralized kind of tech stack
because i think
one of the the unfortunate things
there's a lot of people running around
saying that they're building
decentralized
products or networks and then you're
like wait a second you just run it on
like
amazon aws like how are you
decentralized right or
uh my favorite uh way to uh to pinpoint
decentralization is if i ask somebody
uh if the government came and told you
to shut it down could you
nope right well no but i'm saying when
somebody is not
fully decentralized it's like look if
they if they threaten to put you in jail
can you shut it down
and they say yes it's like okay then
you're obviously not decentralized right
um and so help us understand kind of
what you guys are building and why
that's important
so it is a good metric um i do want to
note that
that is because of the transition from
ip to
services to um like the
blockchain um initial so theoretically a
government could shut down
you know bitcoin by scanning the old irs
channel for all the
um ip addresses and urls of peers saying
like hey we're part of the bitcoin
network
there those lists you can get pretty
easily in blacklist
which is not good for the network um and
then you could theoretically also shut
you know bitcoin down and
dangerous ethereum comments here by
contributing code
to to bitcoin core right and creating
some sort of breaking
back door change that then eventually
gets propagated out to
all the machines so there's still points
of centralization even in
um a lot of these tools but i do think
that the most pragmatic way to look at
it is from a network standpoint which is
yeah
like are there enough machines pointed
to a single amazon server that
you shut that down and shut down the
network so
what we're building i
let me explain two layers
here there is blockchain right
actually i i care about
providing like comprehensive
understanding so the the decentralized
world is actually broken into three
this microcosm is broken into three
camps
um blockchain crypto
and d-web now most people apply crypto
to
cryptocurrency but no crypto is really
cryptography
the old cypherpunk movement that's
privacy so the value
the values of crypto is is
privacy and that's the kind of signal
telegram
um world and as to whether they're
actually private or not you know
that's a debate on its own that people
know about telegram and signal
then there is blockchain and its values
are
an iran sense of greed so i'm not saying
that negatively i'm saying that like
that the selfish individual can then
contribute back to society
and build up um profit which then
reinvested into um the larger network
but but like the values of blockchain
really is
greed oriented in an iran sense that
they should have used a better word um
than
being selfish and then d web is honestly
about
freedom or inclusivity
it can kind of go both ways let's say
that those are fundamentally the same
value at the end of the day
it's it's hard to have freedom if you're
exclusive and you're creating yet
another
wild garden so
my technology in my company has kind of
quickly evolved
from um
people talking about it in this
intellectual decentralized kind of
bitcoin narrative that all the rest of
the market
is caught up in to actually okay
but the applied use of this technology
is actually extremely beneficial for
companies existing enterprises as well
as individuals
non-profits and um governments so
from like a business perspective i'm
saying
this cloud edge market is a
larger bubble it's a larger
market share to attack than necessarily
this ideologically purest
view i i am an ideological purist
but i have to be a ruthless pragmatist
and unfortunately
my goal is adoption right
not necessarily um who's got
a larger market cap on their crypto coin
so for me we've already onboarded 30
million
monthly active users and over the next
one or two years with the existing
companies and enterprises i'm working
with
it'll be growing to about 100 million
monthly active users
and so i'm just desperately trying to
keep up with these
non-profits and enterprises that want to
get that type of radical efficiency
gains
and underneath i then feel ethically
okay
that while maybe i'm transitioning a
existing centralized service into being
increasingly more decentralized and
resilient
um that that also on boards all of the
users
of that service slowly into
decentralization without them even
knowing it
and that's because the value add of
privacy
alone while extraordinarily important
only resonates
with a much much smaller market size
than the value add of convenience
and because i care philosophically
about this transition of humanity
towards a better more empathic
um humanitarian less controlled less
dystopian dictator type
internet i have to then
be practical in saying hey you know
we're actually going to
give you 70 cost savings on your
existing infrastructure
by switching over this technology um but
that means the bar is much much
higher because now
my technology is and has to be
continuously
battle tested at a scale that's
significantly significantly larger than
what most blockchains
are testing against that doesn't mean
i'm anti-blockchain it just means
i have a very industrialist
view of how to go about humanitarian
transitions
and i will make those um in-between
steps
if necessary rather than um being
entirely purist
who or what are the types of
organizations and people
that kind of are first adopting this
right
like what is there certain verticals is
there certain types of businesses or
individuals that you're just like this
is where we're finding the
the receptivity is an interesting one
so it's it's definitely a power rule um
you get
thousands of people to come into
something and then honestly you know
it's the one
the 10 the 100 um that have
the impact so internet archive is this
incredible non-profit
please go donate to them they they did
the pandemic response where they opened
up their library
um for like medical textbooks and other
things to
to effectively everybody and then the
publishers suit them but they're like
there's this non-profit that's just like
literally has the internet backed up
um so they are decentralizing their
backup of the internet a historical
record
of our cultural evolution and our times
as an important transition that's
happening in humanity
they have it all backed up in like two
data centers both in northern california
uh
up um near the presidio and then one
over in um
richmond area so i as well as some of
the other d
web um protocols are
helping transition um i
ideally the backup of that data off
onto just random laptops running around
the world
even phones in our case now
there's certainly a different
reliability guarantee
but it's increasing the resilience and
so i'd say that reliability
can possibly go down in decentralized
systems
if your network is not large enough um
however efficiency and
resilience goes up in a decentralized
network so i'm going to archive
go donate to them they're incredible uh
they're a great example and
initially they were using us for
metadata what is the
the small piece of the data to
coordinate all the information in the
system
however um i started working with some
people on their team about a half year
ago
on uh taking their video um archive
of public domain movies and
and decentralizing that as well my
technology was not i did not originally
intend to build it
for video services gun
as a database was intended for small
data points like gps coordinates
that are updating hundreds of times a
second in a decentralized network
or tweets small pieces of data
metadata-like information
and syncing that in a network however
mozilla
just came along and sponsored our zoom
alternative
i can send you the link to that it's
called meat thing and we are
literally i would have offered to do it
unless you know you already
have zooms you're kind of processed for
recording video that
we're literally live streaming video
through our network um through our
decentralized technology
so mozilla's helped us uh with with
sponsoring that
so mozilla is another organization in
there and then there's a couple other
teams that are doing kind of video like
stuff so
lately a lot of the use case has been
around video um
i think that's important it's not what
i'm like
in gold passionate about but it's
helpful
the next company that's using washington
state startup
is a youtube alternative and
they are where probably a big chunk of
that 30 million monthly active users are
coming from
um i don't really want to say their name
because
uh being a youtube alternative that is
censorship resistant leads
to some pretty bad marketing um stuff
so i'm going to skip on to the next one
which is hacker noon we are
experimenting with hacker noon which is
the
tech journal they have about four
million monthly active users
um they kind of pitched it as storing
uh annotations and comments on our
blockchain of technology which
is is accurate but
not not entirely
accurate um so we were
testing with them like okay how do we
manage four million monthly
active users and distributing their load
and their costs which i think that
they're open about that i can disclose
like they have credits with google for
about four thousand dollars a month that
they're getting charged
for four million monthly active users
and we were
um benchmarking comparable um
performance where we're running on
effectively four dollars of
quote infrastructure costs because we're
able to actually spread the load
across that many users on their network
um but again i want to be clear if you
only have four users
in your network it's going to be very
hard to get
the sort of efficiency and scaling gains
and most unfortunately blockchain
products only have like a
four or a couple hundred users a month
on it which means they have to run
these server-side backups but when your
network is very large
the value is in your network and you can
then spread the load across the network
but you have to have a priority a large
a large network and there's plenty of
other examples i could talk about but
those kind of the four
biggest ones um again like
usually it's a handful of users that
represent the majority of the traffic
even with
like 12 000 developers how to start our
project there's there's lots of
interesting um one-off developer
projects
but they are definitely not at the scale
as
these uh subset of companies
can the entire internet be decentralized
like is that the
the ultimate endgame here is everything
is decentralized
it comes back to technical explanation
of what decentralization means and
there's fundamentally two modes
right um one mode is what's called
broadcast or mesh
based communications and broadcast or
mesh based communications
do not scale well um they're great for
things like burning man
protests um your local area wi-fi
and actually even probably larger stuff
because
iot is going to be very important with
mesh you have self-driving cars
that should literally be bypassing cell
towers
and emitting um their signals or gps
coordinates for doing things called dead
reckoning for pre-calculating where cars
should drive
and to not um collide with each other as
self-driving cars start to talk to each
other like that
is all mesh based and that is
geographically and biomass uh um
concentrated so mesh systems are good
for physically
um physically dense
areas however across the pond
communications from
san francisco to new york like with us
or to london
you you decentralization does not
scale in terms of mesh communication but
you can still achieve decentralization
at a global scale um
and that's part of the reason why our
technology is able to scale so well is
is you intelligently kind of detect
whether
the packets or messages in the network
are intended
for an external network in which case
you don't rebroadcast it to everybody in
your local area
you you discover you do a path finding
algorithm
to discover what is the fastest and most
efficient way of communicating that
information
um and that keeps it scalable
because you effectively
have federated or centralized
like routing but is distinct from the
algorithms themselves
being centralized with respect to
ownership
right because if that's all running
through google's network or verizon's
network
that's that's bad or comcast network but
if you're if you're able to
figure out this routing um
a good analogy here is you have the
united states of america you want to
drive from san diego to
new york there's many different states
you could drive through
there's many different combinations and
there's a more efficient route they
could drive through
um but what if there's a big massive
toll
right right like smack dab on the most
efficient route there's this wall
there um you might want to take a longer
route and drive around
um and see different countryside so you
can think of
routing communication internet as being
the same thing
and the goal is now like free market
competition of
available routing right and as long as
you keep
that highly available then it's
decentralized even if you're getting
even if most of your packets are being
sent um
through google's fiber optic cables or
att's
uh cable because if that cable goes down
whether
physically or um financially right at
regulation or something
you're able to route around it maybe
it's not as efficient
but um decentralization is all about
getting all these people in a network to
agree to the same protocol
to have a more resilient system but
achieve the same efficiency as a
centralized system
where it is optimally possible
got it and so help people understand
like what is the
um the best way for them to think about
uh you use this terminology like
database for freedom fighters
right and kind of like before we kind of
get into the rapid fire to finish up
explain that a little bit like what does
that mean
taking a danger you're gonna turn into a
much much longer territory so
um our psychologists our team
our behavior analysis and our marketing
analysis
has kind of looked at different cultures
across the world and been able to
consolidate um
down to three fundamental values there's
a lot more than that and there's all
sorts of interesting talks from
um jonathan height to others i can send
you to
but the three cultural values are are
freedom fairness
and fusion um i never really thought
about fusion before because
i'm western and fusion winds up being
strongly
asian and i i honestly don't know enough
about it yet but i know that that's
something that has to be on the table
uh and if i ignore it i'm not being
appropriately
objective freedom is just like classic
right american
um fairness is where you get a lot of
um european values as well as
progressive
left values which is like we're focused
well i shouldn't say we but those people
um whether that includes you or me or
uh is focused on on care
over justice and this plays out in all
sorts of interesting ways especially
with
the justice versus the riots going on
now um
and capitalists people who focus on
freedom
usually interpret fairness from a equity
perspective
rather than a
um so if
somebody works hard and builds a company
they believe that the merit and the
reward should go to that person
not distributed across the goal that
what is fair
what is just what is equitable as the
person who did the work
gets the results and the same thing with
respect to
crime right if somebody commits a crime
then that person should be individually
punished for it
not society as a whole okay and
unfortunately most humans
kind of want the rewards to be
distributed across everybody
and the punishment to be isolated to the
individual
um that would be like probably
the optimal balance of everybody's
philosophical and ideological views
while fairness if you don't take it from
a justice or named view
is oh it's not fair if there's this
scarce
pie and only one percent or 20 percent
of
people have it and 80 have this wealth
divide
but where this gets like particularly
intersectionally um
toxic or fascinating is then around like
justice police brutality is is terrible
we need to immediately stop it
but then how do you reconcile like oh
is is burning down um
other people's houses or businesses
or um government buildings public
buildings justified
in distributing justice across
um and we don't really as humans we
don't really want to talk about
distributing justice we don't really
want to talk
that makes us uncomfortable okay so if
you want to skip this from your podcast
feel free to edit it out
um but those are like the values that we
have to struggle with
and now i forget your your question
that's what i'm talking about fusion
that's not even talking about the
conflict of governments
of you know of the the united states
perspective relative to eight
to china and russia which are the other
kind of driving cultural influences
but um yeah okay sorry what was the
question
um the idea of the database for freedom
fighters
like where exactly um
that is uh kind of prevalent and
kind of what that means
i would i would argue it is hard to have
justice in fairness
if there's always a middle man
controlling
what that justice is and so that means
because of my american view my
my more capitalist leaning perspective
while i i understand that there are
particular flaws and loopholes
that i do see freedom as being
foundational
in order to reduce
it it goes back to this resilience idea
in order to maintain
fairness and fusion for larger scales of
people without it becoming corrupt
you need freedom as a foundational
component
and ignoring
any political process of that just
technologically that's a nuanced
detail that like impacts
like in all humans so yes if we all were
using apple computers or ibm servers
or amazon servers it doesn't matter our
political affiliations or a political
view
if all internet has to be trafficked
through a particular machine
then we are fundamentally at risk
to the interests of that individual
whether we agree with it or not from
cutting off
everybody else um we just
hope right that the people that we're
trafficking our internet through
um and our technology through we agree
with and the same thing that's playing
out with like usps
and the post office system right which
is like well
i want options of being able who can i
mail through
right um the more free market
competition that exists so
so the reason why i called it gun
is because historically and yes still
in the present day um wars were fought
with
bullets and the danger there
is around who could amass the most guns
the most bullets and
coerce a population but what we have
seen
with the rise of google and facebook and
the privacy violations
and even zoom doing all sorts of
nefarious stuff
is that this transition has moved to
digital warfare um which is taking
people's personalities and their minds
their psychology and their behaviors
and their their purchasing powers and
their voting powers and using
the database as a gun
to coerce or manipulate um people and
programmers love power
it's dangerous for us people and so i
want to constantly remind
developers whether they're at google or
corporate or at a government
or um the individual developers in our
community
that the database how you manage
people's information is a loaded weapon
you have to take as much caution with
how you use that data as you would
with real physical um
wobbles and boundaries and guns
and once we kind of get
the the googles and the facebooks of the
world to realize
that the real danger
of the information that they have access
to
then maybe we can upsell them
on transitioning to something else
um which i'm all for win-win system so i
don't really want to burn down
governments i don't want to burn down
corporations i don't want to burn down
the individual
i want to figure out how to align the
incentives between governments
corporations and individuals such at the
end of the day
yes my communication with anybody in the
world is end-to-end encrypted
which we have the technological tooling
for
and there is some sort of middleman or
government
that's our middleman uh corporation that
is trying to deliver my data at faster
and faster rates
um as well as in governments that see
the value add
in information propagation rather than
information
disinformation um and
i'll end it there if you're interested
in where i'm going with all that
thinking
it fundamentally requires post-scarce
economic models
um beyond debt based models
you still have to be compatible with
existing system so i would encourage
anybody to check out my free eco and
then i have
um a talk called um opt out of money
for fun and profit and it discusses how
you can actually
combine both of these worlds to create
and evolve people into more pro-social
settings more humanitarian set
settings that are also equally as
profitable lucrative
and um financially
incentivized as
as existing debt-based models so we can
send people
first to free.eco they can go read a
bunch of content
right that you've created there and if
they want to check out the product they
can go to gun dot eco
right is the best uh website all right
so people go check out that
um i think that obviously the the
importance of uh
decentralized infrastructure in the
future world is uh
uh could never be more obvious is then
i'll kind of leave it at that
uh before i go to wrap up mark i always
ask same two questions and then you'll
get to ask me a question to uh to end it
uh the first one is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
um i might be an outlier here i've
probably read less than 50 books in my
entire life
um i i i'm actually pretty
anti-book so i don't have a good answer
for you
what do you do instead of read books
write books so
what's the most important one you've
written
um it depends upon whether you want a
fact or fiction in fact
i would say the the free eco blogs
because because that's the most
important relevant relevant to
you to humanity at this time and its
transition
but i would encourage people to
independently go and write about this
stuff before being influenced
by my writings i don't i want people to
rederive these things separately
not be manipulated by me so um if you
want to read it go ahead
please do but i would encourage people
to write books
rather than read books not that reading
books is bad it's great
it's just you learn more by teaching
than you do by
being a student so i love that answer
uh second question a little bit more fun
is aliens believer or non-believer
um okay uh i i
think that i think that
information is the most alien thing
and so with with elon musk's
neural link and uh mary lou jepson's
um uh non-invasive
infrared or whatever um read write brain
stuff
we're going to be thrown into an
informational
universe and if you watch tron 2
i do think that that there is
possibility for the emergence
of alien entity or information whether
that just be ai
okay or whether that be like some
alien that existed from millions and
millions of years ago that like
got sucked into a black hole or so like
like so no i don't i don't believe
in aliens because i haven't seen
scientific evidence of aliens existence
but i do think that alien information or
alien entities can arise
or emerge in which case
it's just a question of locality do they
exist in information space
do they exist in physical space um
as to whether you bump into them and
there's a big probability that
when we throw ourselves into information
space universe that we're never going to
bump into them because
all of our information space systems are
currently centralized to earth
right so um i would actually argue that
like trees
and um the texture on the back of my
wall
are just as important from an alien
searching perspective because from an
information theory
in order to preserve larger and larger
amounts of data
so take the internet archive right
taking a picture
of of cultural history on the internet
and making that available ideally to
people hundreds thousands of years from
now
you want to compress that information
however as you compress information it
becomes increasingly less
readable and looks increasingly more
natural so it is possible the answer to
life the universe and everything
has actually been like encoded into the
the wood grains
on on this paneling here and i as a
human would
would not even notice because it just
looks like chaos or noise to me
um so hopefully that kind of plays
around with ideas of aliens and
information
i love it you could ask me one question
to finish up what's the one question you
got for me
next 10 years where do you think
humanity is going to be at
alive so we're not going to die
what uh what do you mean where is it
going to be at in what sense
population levels as well as market
levels right
a sign that's hidden two questions but i
for me
right like i'm always curious about the
end goal that you're trying to achieve
versus short-term goals so anthony
over the next decade um whether it be
you individually or your philosophy
where humanity should go
where do you or humanity uh you think
humanity ought to be in ten years and
whether that's achievable or not
it sounds like you're kind of
pessimistic that yeah no i think it's um
i always say like my goal is just to be
happy right and like that's like a super
unmeasurable goal that is
you know kind of individualistic in uh
in
um kind of evaluation but to me like as
long as you're happy then like
you've won like i i don't know i've got
a very unique view on this i think in
that like
i just i'm constantly reminded like
we're all going to die you're not you're
not getting out alive
so like enjoy it right and uh
it's one of these things of uh every
morning when i wake up like
i this sounds really weird but literally
it's just a shot clock
like today's gonna tick by tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick
and when today's over you don't get it
back and then tomorrow you can do it
again
and you're gonna get you know thousands
of those kind of
days uh but once it's over it's over
so uh you know everything else kind of
against that backdrop is uh
is pretty uh not important from
from a high level and then when you dig
into the weeds like are there other
things that are important of course
uh but i think it kind of refocuses you
on like what do you want to actually
spend your time on
right the science is behind you happy
people wind up contributing happiness
back to the world at larger and larger
profits so that is very very true my
friend
um all right so listen anyone who's
interested
in decentralized infrastructure for a
future world if anyone
agrees with my general thought process
that centralization is a business risk
please go check out uh gun.ego
where you can find out more about the
database technology and decentralized
decentralized technologies that mark and
team are building um and then if you
want to learn more about the
uh philosophy and kind of thought
process you can go to free.eco
um anywhere else you want to send people
are you on twitter anything yes
mark nadal at twitter i tweet about all
these subjects quite a lot
so it'll be easy for me to engage in
dialogue conversation the lovely twitter
um
debates and about you to other
interesting articles
whether it be the empathic civilization
or the economics stuff
awesome man well let's thank you so much
for doing this let's do it again in the
future
have a great one thanks so much for
having me on